if there's one thing we love more than
our favorite Disney Princess it is to
see many of them at the same time we
discovered that many of these characters
lived in the same universe as there are
many connections between them when you
know where the boat from The Little
Mermaid comes from you'll never look at
it the same way again
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're telling you more about 10
Disney princess connections that will
make your jaw drop The Little Mermaid
and Moana these two Disney Princesses
couldn't be more different one of them
wanted to leave the sea to live on land
while the other one wanted to leave the
land to live out on sea Ariel had pale
skin and red wavy hair and the
Polynesian character had brown skin and
curly brown hair but what could be the
link between these two princesses in the
last video we saw that flounder made a
quick swim onto the screen you probably
missed it if you blinked but he was
there during the song you're welcome and
this time we won't forget Ariel's other
best friend there was one thing these
two young women both did meeting a crab
Sebastian was the mermaids best friend
who wanted to help her realize her
dreams
even though they wouldn't be able to
swim together in the sea anymore Tama
Toa on the other hand was a little less
kind the monstrous hermit crab had
acquired Maui's magical fishhook among
with many other treasures the two
friends managed to escape with the hook
and Tama Toa was flipped onto his back
this was when he said that if his name
was Sebastian and that he had a Jamaican
accent they would totally help him this
was a not-so-subtle reference to the sea
creature we all know and we have to
admit that this moment made us all laugh
Sleeping Beauty and The Little Mermaid
Ariel is not only connected to one but
many universes royalty is all about
family so it's not surprising that some
of our favorite Disney characters are
related but we never expected a Disney
character who lived in the 14th century
to be seen centuries later in the 19th
century many fans claimed that they saw
a picture of aurora and Prince Phillip
hanging on the wall in the dining room
of Eric's castle it could be seen when
Ariel was having dinner with the prince
on her first night on land as you can
see
the blonde woman was wearing the same
blue dress and golden crown as Aurora
the man also had a hairstyle that makes
him look like Prince Philip according to
this theory Erik might be the direct
descendant of the couple from Sleeping
Beauty almost 500 years after this would
explain why the painting was in his
castle and the ancestors and
great-grandson also shared one
similarity they both fell in love with
the voice of a woman or maybe Disney
just wanted to remind us at the last
movie they did even though we will
probably never really know who these two
people are we want to agree with those
who thought about this theory make sure
to watch this video to the end to know
another youniverse Ariel is connected to
Aladdin and many movies Genie was
probably one of the funniest Disney
cartoon characters spending 10,000 years
in the lamp made him a little crazy but
that was what we loved about him he
didn't mind impersonating someone else
including our favorite characters his
best transformations from the first
movie and Aladdin and the King of
Thieves
included Pocahontas when he jumped off a
plane and Pinocchio also made a brief
appearance you could even see genie pull
Sebastian out of his bag of tricks only
the greatest actor could voice so many
characters and his name is Robin
Williams when recording voices the actor
improvise so much that they had almost
16 hours of material this is also the
reason why the script was rejected for
Best Adapted Screenplay Academy Award
nomination Williams ad-lib too much and
after all this we think that the result
was worth much more than an award but
how can this character know about all
this even though he lives centuries
before and spent thousands of years in a
lamp many fans believe that Aladdin
jasmine and genies never existed this
was nothing but a story told by the
seller who wanted to convince us to buy
an old lamp this could explain why this
movie was so perfect it was too good to
be true
brave and monsters Inc you wouldn't
think that the main female characters
from these two movies have anything in
common but what is the connection
between the cute and dependent little
boo and the strong and independent grown
up Merida according to some fan theories
these two girls actually met each other
many people believe that the character
from monsters
grew up to be the witch and brave you
need an explanation according to this
theory boo would grow up learning magic
monsters will be the source of
inspiration for her favorite trick
disappearing through doors and since she
would learn how to travel from one room
to another she could also travel in time
this is how she would go back centuries
before to the dark ages but she would
keep something to remind her of her
childhood a carving of Sulley you can
clearly see the monster in the movie and
we can't deny that one some fans also
believe that brave explained the reason
why some animals behave like humans
Merida discovered magic and accidentally
turned her mother into a bear this might
explain why animals have human
characteristics she is probably not the
only one who made this kind of mistake
what do you think about these series
Beauty and the Beast and Aladdin if you
watched our first video you already know
that Belle's favorite book was actually
about a movie we all know she described
it as a story that happened in far-off
places with sword fights magic spells
and a prince in disguise so it is pretty
clear that this could be a reference to
Prince Ali and Jasmine's love story and
actually there are many other
connections between Beauty and the Beast
and Aladdin when the bookworm was
walking around the city you could see
something that belonged to the thief it
is difficult to see but a man might be
holding a magic carpet he will probably
be surprised when he finds out about
what this thing can do as the movie
about the thief was released only a year
after Beauty and the Beast we could bet
the creator's gave us these two hints to
let us know what was coming next and if
this is not enough to convince you we
have spotted something else in the movie
Aladdin when the Sultan was stacking up
a bunch of toys figurines and Jafar
caused him to tumble you could see a
character we all know amongst them it
was the Beast
these characters will probably never
meet each other as they live centuries
apart but if they did they would
probably see that they have seen each
other before Snow White in the Seven
Dwarfs and tangled stepmothers can be
wonderful women but not when it comes to
Disney movies Snow White and Rapunzel
were two unlucky young women who lived
with one of these main characters the
first princess had to run away from her
castle when the Queen
asked the hunter to get rid of her and
come back with her heart and mother
Gothel locked Rapunzel in a castle for
over two years so she could use the
power of her hair to make the clock
reverse these two evil characters shared
many similarities and this is why some
fans think that these two stepmothers
were actually the same person they both
wanted to be the fairest of them all
the Queen was jealous of Snow White's
beauty and Mother Gothel didn't mind
using the blonde princess to stay young
forever moreover they were both witches
who use their power against the princess
are you wondering how this woman managed
to be part of these two stories even
though they were centuries apart tangled
gave you the explanation for this mother
Gothel was really old at the beginning
of the movie just like the Queen would
be the magic flower was the reason why
she looked so young and as you can see
when these two characters looked like
old hags they were actually pretty much
the same the Queen already survived one
fall and she could survive the other one
tangled and many movies
Rapunzel is not only connected to one
movie but to many of our favorite
characters
Rapunzel discovered many things when she
escaped a tower and so did we
during the whole film you could see many
cameos or references to our favorite
stories and tangles for example you
could see Pinocchio in the snuggly
duckling he was on the top right corner
in the rafters right after Cupid was
swung to the right of the screen in the
same scene you could see Pumbaa from The
Lion King the reason why we saw them
during the song I've got a dream was
because they had a dream - Pinocchio
wanted to be a real boy and Pumbaa
wanted to be accepted despite having bad
gasps and they were not the only ones
you could see in the movie
there were many references to our
favorite Disney Princesses including the
spinning wheel from Sleeping Beauty the
apple from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs a dresser and a rose from Beauty
and the Beast a shell from The Little
Mermaid and a slipper from Cinderella
moreover when Rapunzel was looking for
something in a book you could see the
books of Beauty and the Beast The Little
Mermaid and Sleeping Beauty these are
all good reasons to watch this movie
again to see if we can spot all these
things Sleeping Beauty and Snow White
and the Seven Dwarves
these two stories were pretty similar
the two princesses dreamed of finding
the love of their life before they were
put into a deep sleep because of a mean
character
there were also tiny people taking care
of them the dwarfs let Snow White live
in their house and the short fairy
godmothers raised Aurora as their own
daughter but the most important thing
that made these two women so special was
that they had been saved by the kiss of
a prince this is why Walt Disney's
constant mantra when working on Sleeping
Beauty was that the film could not be
like Snow White in the Seven Dwarves
but that didn't keep them from using the
first movie as inspiration for Sleeping
Beauty the idea of the couple dancing
the clouds is a finale it was supposed
to be used at the finale for Snow White
but it was only part of Sleeping Beauty
years later moreover many ideas
discarded from the first Disney princess
movie were used in this new story it
included the prince being captured and
escaping the castle it wasn't part of
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs because
Walt Disney didn't believe animators
could draw a male character believably
enough The Little Mermaid and frozen
these two girls were both known for one
thing water The Little Mermaid lived
under the sea and the Queen controlled
water that was much colder with her ice
power they also liked hiding away in a
secret place a sunken ship and an ice
castle but these are not the only
connections between Elsa and Ariel water
was actually the source of a tragic
event for the ice queen and the reason
why the mermaid made an amazing
discovery many fans believe that the
boat in which Elsa's parents were
traveling was the one that the mermaid
found under water
there was a shipwreck in the storm and
the boat sunk only for Ariel to discover
it years later no one confirmed this
theory but the co-director of frozen
chris buck is not against this idea he
already confirmed that in his heart
Elsa's parents didn't pass away on the
ship they were washed up on the shore of
a jungle built a tree house and had a
little baby boy buck didn't say anything
about the Little Mermaid but he said
something that makes us believe in the
theory he said that whatever people want
to believe they should go for it if we
want to tie these two movies together we
could do it that's the spirit of Disney
Mickey Mouse and the Disney Princess
movies all the Disney Princesses had
something in common no they were not all
princesses from the start and not all of
them needed a man to save their lives
but they were all heroes of a movie
produced by Disney and to make sure that
you remember this the creator's hit a
little character in many films you can
see Mickey Mouse the mascot in most of
the movies the famous character was
already part of the first Disney
princess movie Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs you could see him in the bubble
around dopey then in Cinderella our
favorite little mouse was hiding in the
bubbles again it was easier to see him
in the Little Mermaid as he was in the
audience at the concert in Beauty and
the Beast he was more subtle in the
decorations in Aladdin Rajah was even
transformed for a moment you could also
see Disney's mascot on the necklace of
the Queen from tangled and in one of the
latest movies frozen Mickey Mouse was on
the Shelf so this makes all the Disney
Princesses connected in some way these
are all great reasons to do a Disney
movie marathon and see if we can find
the little mouse in our favorite films
and that's it for 10 Disney princess
connections that will make your jaw drop
is there any theory that you don't
believe in tell us what you think in the
comments below subscribe to our channel
for more stories like this and if you
haven't seen it yet don't forget to
watch 10 Disney Princess connections
that will make your jaw drop part 1
thanks for watching
[Music]